how's gum right got a do my hair look
good for your brows facecam so I think
call me crazy but I think we call it
we're nearing the end of the game which
is always a very bittersweet feeling
because you know you want to know how it
ends but you don't want it to end
surprisingly throughout the game I don't
really want to ten I kind of wanted to
continue for a long time which is good
that's a good sign right but uh I don't
love the game yet I like it we'll see
how the ending goes we'll see how it
will affect us and spend a lot of tarry
parts already so we're waking up oh yeah
replies you got a hit in the [ __ ]
head dude I smell a major plot twist are
we gonna be in Dawkins office or some
[ __ ] like that
oh cool
they did open the rift wait are we
inside the rift who's that is that Daddy
Dafoe is that that it fo the most
powerful condenser I've ever created
I am the [ __ ] something happened you
lost weight look exhausted
I guess suits going too pretentious it's
pretty pimpin please have a seat
how do you feel I've been better that
hit on the head did not help I'm sorry I
told them not to hurt you I just didn't
want to give you a chance to use I
didn't why don't you just [ __ ] invite
him then I guess we talked about Nora
what her mom
yeah one [ __ ] out wasn't stable they
were afraid she was a danger to herself
and her baby it's not Jennifer hurt me
they couldn't take that chance look I
was a researcher at the DPA Jodi I
didn't discover it till much later what
happened why didn't you tell me what
about the CIA how'd they find me
I've been tracking you ever since your
escapes they wanted to kill you but I
convinced them to wait for a while watch
you from the distance wait for a while I
want the truth
Dawkins you never tell me about my
mother oh yeah hide the truth all these
years I tried to tell you that's not
good enough but how do you tell a little
girl that her life isn't real so I
looked after you loved you tried to
protect you as best as I could
so now you're just gonna hand me back to
the CIA is that the plan Nathan they
brought you here because they have
something for you to do and they'd be
very grateful if you do it let's be bit
help them you want me to help the people
that took away my mother and stole my
life have I done enough we nurture
another country is discovered the m4
world they think it's something to be
controlled or manipulated they have no
idea what they're dealing with
if entities enter our world do you know
what that would mean Jody not a good
party what is all this got to do with me
because you know the infant world better
than anyone it's the CIA's job and I'm
done with that
I didn't know the CIA was Oh idea I was
this for them and they let me go let you
are you're free that sounds like a done
Little Italy dad hold it there are
thousand people me the power to stop
this when we already saw the future and
we already thought I'd happening I guess
we saw the apocalypse hubris remember on
the term according to our Intel the
Republic of Kazakhstan has just taken
assistance of the import Republic drift
conducting experiments from a secret
base located in the province of high/low
Jim five years Howard staged their in
their experiments what we've detected
important fluctuations within the infra
world that means they've found a way to
interact with the other son now your
mission is to destroy this condenser and
yet as technology you find even if we
manage to destroy the condenser the rift
will still be there Billy a condenser is
a costly and time-consuming business but
this operation will gain time to better
understand the world and to make sure
that no one trying to use it against us
it's Americans you should expect
considerable military resistance Dean
will team
I'm not that dick not working with that
dick hole
don't be the [ __ ]
don't be the [ __ ] don't be the day
baby good to see you girl what it's the
decade
Clayton's team goes with you small agile
commando unit able to avoid detection
it's gonna be juicy missions into jülich
juicier than my dad dad dad dad dead Dan
Jack dan dan dan be careful Jody that's
what you said this with you're gonna
find on the other side don't worry I
don't think I'm ready to try that in
four well yeah I guess that's what
happens in the prologue because I don't
want to lose you well how about you step
up be a man you know don't wear that
ugly vest those guys doing it's good to
see you don't you [ __ ] dare talk to
me aggressive looks like I didn't
remembers me keep your distance Ryan I
didn't is even less forgiving than I
oh the classical walking to the other
person while you walk away let's move in
the book highly effective so of course
we're going to how did they call it oh
damn what's happening now that doesn't
look too too good
hey oh [ __ ] sorry about you know about
this the refuse to cooperate I will have
no choice but to kill you
insecure I can you take that guy for you
I will kill you regardless now very slow
agonizing death uh-huh so I ask you one
last time who do you work for
yeah where is he I can't click on it
what was up with a we can't use fevers
with it twist like that it's completely
deserted
you sure it's here we're right on top of
the coordinates don't get worse huh what
do we do now
that's me of Inception Jodi asked hiding
to find a shelter somewhere oh I get it
I have to do all the dirty work
surprising what I'm what I'm more than
what fit through that mission and that
that's not-- but the help eat sensor yes
shelter got it not any of these happy
houses they're not that great I don't
know how about this this doesn't look
too bad you can just dig a hole in the
snow that's what you do right there's a
boat there I think I think the boat will
be fine you're freezing here that
doesn't look too good
there's just a lot of hot got it let's
go
yeah skiing
dubrovsky or snowboard or neither
I ski I try to learn snowboard but I am
pretty powerful I skied since I was a
kid it would make sense for me they
literally could have just walked 5 feet
they just had to make me do that why it
must be those Chinese lands oh yeah
we're in China arguing
hello I'm like a couple years like it's
almost always Russian news and amis and
now China is becoming that or at Korea's
never becoming enemies and it's like it
could it be just some [ __ ] random
each country like Sweden or some [ __ ]
like I'd be offering this that would
that would be awesome no worries it's
like we're [ __ ] done with a [ __ ]
we're gonna know for nothing [ __ ] I'm
sick and tired of hearing you
complaining that's all you have to say
that shut the [ __ ] up oh geez guys I'm
freezing you think maybe we could build
a fire first and argue later this is
right
set up camp here to the storm blows over
I'll contact HQ instructions maybe now I
should have my ride I'm sorry for
talking over the dialogue there um am I
gonna help this [ __ ] I'm not gonna take
part in any of these see what it's doing
probably watching you porn again let's
see yeah yep I knew it that's what you
say now what a hell are they doing over
there
damn oh stuff soaking
you better find something they want more
like the Sam Sam glam [ __ ] genius
Vince you see that Jody that's funny are
you doing buddy what are you doing Nick
yeah you're not talking to anyone I'm
doing any sexy dude isn't really - forty
dayum
oh yeah I remember Fahrenheit the
exaggerated so much the temperatures
ridiculous like - 668 Celsius or some
[ __ ] like that
like I don't think anyone can live in
that oh you're kidding there Joey
I mean they gotta be awkward to pee if I
dance around I never give that a thought
why am i walking towards this to work
that tired kind of looks like ass boy
watching girls pee great gameplay - Ford
is gonna be so cool that it freezes 2
p.m.
Princess Di's allow her we oughta really
gets to hear in the background watch it
I wonder if she stopped peeing when she
saw you resident I probably keep peeing
probably pee harder I heard it's a great
way to like distract yourself good thing
they weren't on the road they would have
been killed
I probably would have paid over there
not there you know where from the main
road a convoy of armored cars they drove
right by me they see you know what's
wrong
really let's follow that on oh [ __ ]
[Music]
god I always hated getting on the skis
like the worst hey I get to ski I get
the ski to the right I get to ski to the
left
ah skiing like a bow
why are we first and why aren't we
telling any luggage
how did they get the skis off so [ __ ]
fast I didn't go see what's inside God
all right well here we go here it goes
again
Eureka
okay there's this it's just uh the
bathtub a lot of water in it I'm not
sure how they keep the water from not
getting frozen I'm not sharing my dick
shirts and [ __ ] plays like it's a
boat it's a save moraine but that's the
big eye all the sudden I can go so far
nothing whittling crate seat
submarines submarines yes submarines
that means the rift is what I think
there must have a base down there and
they're using the substitution of
supplies some very expensive no many
soldiers
I can see three
tell I'd entertain about watch I didn't
I'm working for the CIA you can't care
me what I do
oh hi did you have breakfast this
morning oh you didn't oh you're about to
oh how nice it's gonna be annoying
trying to build like a science operation
and people just come and [ __ ] the
sabotaging why can't I get a gun like
any other soldier what kind of soldier
are you what's your job anyway
let's [ __ ] this guy hey Jerry hey Jerry
I don't like you Jerry you're obviously
not doing a good job - hey how you doing
ups in anything miss clay tink sir
thanks oh thanks thanks oh thanks thanks
thanks thanks oh thanks thanks thanks
the things I think the things
thanks at things ten seconds
exit itself
- ah thanks
Thanks
[Music]
they chess I wish I could make him jump
in the water Sunday morning so did she
guess what would you now go into summary
second okay please let it be going in
the submarine actually there's the
control thing here let's check that out
oh the Fed Marine is fat hey Sharon
maybe we can use it yeah sure let's use
their so they will notice anything I'm
looking for a plan not a way to commit
suicide no wait what exactly are you
doing
finding us my job problem nice idea but
it won't fool them very long maybe not
she kind of looks Asian so it's perfect
it's not gonna shut down by itself is it
yeah yeah no fast for a distance than
Wi-Fi fast this change ever this up down
to the base then we take it from there
I'll go with her no you stay here you
find it reject on time we get back
there's a good chance we're gonna have
to move fast
what wait that's an order Nick
give me the explosives
you do realize we might not make it back
alive right now come on don't give me a
gay speech simulator sir
sure [ __ ] sure everyone in the CIA
knows how to had a [ __ ] harvest supper
shouldn't be far
well barrel roll
barrel roll okay so this is how you
drive a submarine huh that looks pretty
cool
oops I hit something Your Mama's ass
that's how bigger this get it was a joke
it's a joke waiting for us
nailed it
like the fishes they have AI my god this
game will sell we [ __ ] - follow the
lines
[Music]
it's not my parents it's really not that
hard I'm doing fine
this bearings me is that it I carry a
joke okay
what happens it hits me no one gives a
[ __ ] okay interesting I've been pretty
[ __ ] terrified but that's just me
being silly
we're gonna see a shark I'd better be a
shark I love sharks
goddamn this thing is not
but that's alright alright
it happens okay there see the lights I
hope that wasn't a question yes yes oh
it's like a
how do they build that on the water that
don't deeply doesn't make any sense
I like the fake nation reminds me of Red
Alert
I am impressed human would have held
that for so long I'm not a man can't you
tell
oh it's tiring my head moral dilemma
we all come not really not really no I
kind of enjoyed he's continuing my
questions are simple I want to know your
name or your work for and how you
learned of the existence of this base of
course you also have to tell me what
happened when you cross the containment
field say nothing you hear me I'm going
to ask the same questions over and over
again until you answer them this is
gonna be homoerotic all you have to do
is answer should be doing I'm coming I
feel like it's part of Le z1s Jody's
character le no se then perhaps you will
not remain silent if I go a little
further
ah what did they do I think cut his arm
this is so unnecessary
you only have to answer and this
nightmare will come to an end and sir
a big why I hate to see people suffer
for nothing
you put deliala
about Walmart on call it in that a real
language an urgent request demands my
attention
I shall return soon to continue our
conversations all right for us hope you
enjoyed this episode of beyond 2 souls
thanks for supporting this series so far
bros maybe like if you enjoyed watching
hit subscribe to become a red today I'll
see you and your pretty face tomorrow
stay awesome chop chop
whoa is that a second point I'm the main
I'm the main man the [ __ ] off